frank ties everything up last season
he's good to go he's got his life back
and then cut to season two just caked in
blood as soon as we see him what
happened what pulls him back in yeah I
think that I think you find I think you
find Frank just flirting with the idea
of peace and quiet and and taking his
foot off the gas for a bit but yeah it
definitely doesn't last long and I think
in that split second where he sees
something happening to her it really
speaks to the nature of not only who he
is deep down at his core but the fact
that I think above all else Frank
Frank's a father you know and he's got a
code that he believes in as much he sort
of sworn off human interaction and
relationships he's not gonna let these
people go after this young woman no
matter what and then you know even
though she and I start quite
adversarially if that's a word we it's
that it's that that that first moment
that first sort of decision to go and be
a protector I think that kind of defines
where the relationship goes through the
through the series right and Georgia
welcome to the Marvel family um tell me
about Amy because she's a character that
I was not familiar with at all what is
her comic background right I mean the
thing is I don't like to go too into the
comic detail because it's a it's loosely
based on the comic character which was
really fun because I got to play around
with you know my own idea of backstory
and where you know her quirks and traits
come from and I kind of got to build
that with a platform that was already
there but I got to kind of you know add
my little little bits and pieces you
find her and she's in some serious
trouble and she's in way over her head
and she doesn't realize it and with the
help of him she um she is alive but it
even kind of more trouble than she
was initially and that's how he kind of
gets pulled into my world and I get
pulled into his world
yeah what was your favorite part about
working together as a team this season
on screen and off my favorite part oh
man look I I can't say say enough good
about about George you know III III I
really I was really blown away by it by
how committed she was on on setting off
she was committed to give everything she
was committed to model her life in New
York around around doing good work as an
actor and that's something that I I just
really admire and I really respect and
and it's you know extraordinarily rare I
think for young actors and it's I'm
really grateful for it we got really
lucky and she's she's she's beautiful
actor a beautiful person and yeah you
know we're gonna be I'm gonna be in her
life whether she wants to be her knob
from here on it yeah ya know I love her
[Music]